Here's your weekend ticket.
- We are the heart and soul of this very beach.
Dwayne Johnson and Zac Efron fight crime and bring the laughs in Baywatch.
- Why does she always look like she is running in slo-mo?
- You see it too?
Its old enemies and new adventures for Jack Sparrow in "Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales".
- Find Sparrow for me.
A crew exploring a distant planet makes an unimaginable and terrifying discovery in Alien Covenant
- Where is it?
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So, what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Download the Fandango app for all the latest showtimes, tickets and trailers
[Pirate accent, presumably]
Get a movie ticket to see Disney's Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales,
when ye buy a 25 dollarrr limited edition Red Robin gift carrrd.
Red Robin!